[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
okay no she remembers okay can I bring
my crew can we come in mom we read about
you I mean it may be me I think nobody
else will do it even if the money is
there yeah why I'm willing to do it I
have a 14 year old son or I have to move
here with yeah yeah there are other
people Mickey Raymond and Frank fruit is
a possibility but how are you going
about looking for people I mean you're
just making contacts and asking if
people are interested or that's right it
has to be someone who can handle money
and has at least German down yeah sure
they said the startup faiths will be
fairly shaky because we don't know
exactly what kind of problems are going
to meet here but I can't remember what
the has believed me you think you too it
is all right well that's good so when
would this be like a training period I
mean as of December 92 then you plan to
have that person up and going and having
the context to get the space and right
and then run it for a year and see if it
can sustain
how much money has to be raised from
donation how much has to be raised some
other way we have good contacts in
Germany England enjoy bringing house
bands so potentially we would run the
bottom floor as some kind of a club or
or you know there are a number of
different angles that could be worth we
could end up booking bands for other
clubs as long as we had a piece of the
action see basically the notion is that
something called the Bohemian Institute
of Prague is going to have an immense
amount of cachet in the United States
and if there's going to be some kind of
expatriate decade here then an
institution like that is as logical as
prognosis when I was here two years ago
I said you know what this town means is
in English weekly and within three
months you know I read that you guys
were up and running so to give people of
expatriate community of focus the
bohemian Institute would be created here
the English freaks the German freaks the
American freaks would all be foreigners
here so II like neutral territory and
it's a real filter by locating it here I
think we would get rid of some of the
hangers on them you do tend to appear if
it were you
Hollywood or London when you say hangers
on a lot of people accuse the expatriate
community here as being just that or or
in seeking out like a second chance city
you know these sort of accusations come
about by starting this sort of
establishment here are you may be making
a little bit more legitimate you know
saying we might actually have something
to contribute to the community we're all
living in more so we just tried to run
away from the problems in America yeah I
mean the idea is that the our analysis
of the problems in America is that they
need a thorough dose of pre 30 years
occult
spiritual idealism well that means
Bohemia that's what it's always meant so
an expatriate community here people here
main who think of it entirely in its
impact on draw but the other is that it
have an impact on American society if
America in politics is going to push
itself over into some kind of super
right wave of situation than any liberal
open-ended criticism of American
societies in ever to come from the
outside the situation is very analogous
in twenties in Paris all those people
were in Paris not because they loved
Paris but because they loved the Harding
administration and republicanism and the
bourgeois leveling of values that was
taking place in the state do you see the
quality of work that's coming out of
Prague and maybe the rest of Jeb's life
yeah so I as well as meeting the level
of what was coming out of the Paris of
the 20s the kind of painting the kind of
writing the kind of excitement or do you
see it as maybe
it's tore in other words in Paris the
surrealist manifesto wasn't until 20
I think that the next two or three years
will tell I think that the practice of
this country is going to be the ultimate
leave unit in hockey Mia as a very fine
thing that what is happening is the
eastern part of the country by taking
itself out of the picture is basically
giving complete permission for the
integration of Bohemia into Western
Europe but amia will move much faster in
stabilizing itself with the country in
two pieces and I'm sure the people who
are nostalgic for Czechoslovakia don't
care for that but I think worldwide
what's happening is a kind of
fragmentation the Danish resistance to
mass trade means it's all fine then
these grand federal unions are planned
by Parliament's and diplomats but when
you ask the people nobody's interested
do you think the quality of Prague right
now is comparable to anything happening
in Paris in the 20s
personally I don't I mean but I've only
been here for six months so now we don't
yet have a stein a Hemingway Faulkner
enjoys a Picasso then established one no
but I'm not saying there wasn't the
nascent well their ears yeah they're
selling sandwiches on the where
something about but in time and I would
hope that this Institute we're talking
about would would be a focus for them
you know certainly nurturing place where
they growing together
what Shake scruffy
- Harrison provide a focus do you I was
speaking with someone else who said that
you have you have the Botanical Gardens
in Hawaii right do you have another
Institute in Northern California or you
establishing one there for this well I
that's why I asked because I want to
know if there is one established there
if this is how it is in contrast or
similar to that one but I don't notice
that well see it it's a somewhat complex
technical problem a non-profit
foundation you probably know this is
called a 501c3 in California what we are
trying to find out is if a Institute run
in Prague can be an American nonprofit
foundation it may be now the reason we
want nonprofit status is to be able to
give people who contribute money a tax
break but often the level of patronage
that we're dealing with people don't
even care about that in other words
we're not going to do this with $50
donation somebody is gonna give us a
twenty five grand or something and
probably they will not be that concerned
about getting their tax break it would
be good for us to establish it as a
non-profit in order that the paying of
the employees than their tax
considerations there so there isn't a
bohemian is to set up in in San
Francisco yet know it but if if it were
to establish yourself here there would
be an office there wouldn't be it's a
parallel venture yes it would probably
be this off of some backside aha oh you
bet I miss that
[Music]
okay
maybe you could speak with me a little
bit about the archaic revival
well yeah that's part of it I mean
what's happening in the states is that
the values of scientific industrialism
developed out of the Renaissance and
classicism and all that it just is it's
played out it's it's finished and an
archaic revival means going back into
time to the last same moment that you
ever knew and then you know attempting
to establish the whatever it was going
on in that moment to reestablish it in
your life now the last same moment that
Europe and by implication American
culture ever knew was the eve of the 30
Years War out of the 30 Years War came
the modern industrial state the modern
parliamentary state and the rise of
modern science and in all cases Bohemia
stood for something else and a
humanizing of science is part of the key
to you know getting the world back on
track so by returning to Bohemia where
this was by first rudolf ii and later by
the winter king and queen brought to
some kind of perfection it seems like
you know a fitting place to have another
deal with this when did the idea of
strike get when were you in san
francisco and you were thinking about
the archaic around elizabeth i I Terence
I'm
go there I must go me apart that's when
when did that happen well strangely
enough it was a year and a half before I
ever got to the first time I came to
Prague because I just I read about the
city knew that it had not been touched
in World War one or World War two was
familiar with some of the photographers
who were out here and just said you know
this will be the place I know it and
people said will be my god you've never
even been there don't you think you
weren't going to look so three years ago
after going to a conference in Linz I
came here with woody and stain of ahsoka
who I check and who are video artists
and they and Woody and I sat down on the
square and talked about it and it seemed
to make sense and then I went to Germany
and told people about it and discussed
it in England and everywhere I went
people said this will work Bohemia
Prague the new freedom in Europe the
rising beige fascism in America the mix
is perfect and this is now my second
trip to Prague and it seems more and
more like we don't have to push this
project it has a natural momentum of its
own
it wants to happen and it doesn't want
to be in Venice or Berlin or Barcelona
it wants to be here you say three years
ago was that immediately after the
Revolution that you came yes okay was
that sort of like you're calling or did
you feel that that your thought so
somehow prescient like a ha this is the
song this is my breakthrough my noon No
checks I had no way to get to Prague and
then came free invitation to fly to Linz
and then the I met wood and stain and he
was Czech we're we've got it they have
with language for five days would you
like to come along a little bit about
your networking from when you met what
is that how have you got about meeting
the bohemian artists here to talking
about your project to really feeling the
momentum pushing you along and that you
weren't pulling well would be was a
graduate of fun and so we knew he knew a
lot of people there and I I don't know
what the situation is in this town now
but at that time faunal had gone from
making seventy pictures in the last year
before the Revolution to making five
pictures the next year so they were
frantic to get money and at first we
envisioned this as maybe a liaison with
fahman where we would you get anything I
wasn't clear how we're doing but then it
was clear that follow is going through
so much upheaval and yosef ketse
apparently there was some criminal and
Happiness or somebody ran off with a
bunch of money you probably know more
about it than I do so it was decided to
not link it to family and then it's
become simply this freestanding kind of
thing since then so with the people that
you've met they just exponentially unit
working out through them and
and meaning people in telling freebasing
yeah and it's not only artists it's also
you know there there was a lot of what
in the West would be called eccentric
science being done here because this pre
rational psychology never really died
out here in campus in the air and the
water and it's what about he Mia reeling
is all about
have you read the for example Frances
book the Rosicrucian well it's the
occult history of Bohemia and of bulimia
Europe and very interesting stuff I mean
this is the place from which all of
these magical ideas were being generated
and perfected throughout the 16th
century and into the 17th right up at
the 30 Years War
I'm 16 and all that I haven't read the
book but but that sort of injury going
on and now this there's trying to
uncertainty I mean in the country it
might split people might there might be
an exodus from Slovakia everything is
sort of up for grabs I mean do you think
that that energy might change that it
might if it does hit a point of economic
disparity and everyone gets way
depressed that that it might lose that
or do you think it could it can't be
touched that it's so magic in it so much
I think it if it could survive communism
what could an economic recession do to I
mean for crying out loud
how would you you said you might if this
really is going or you might have to end
it how would you feel about moving
Czechoslovakian I would my only concern
is that my son and be alright with it he
said he loves the girls and the clothes
of the scene he's a little uncertain
about the language but I would love to
live here I am I've lived at times in
India in Jerusalem and South America and
I could live here and feel less for him
than I ever felt in those places do you
think that the American presence if this
really be it's sort of its one-year
experiment and if that goes very well
and the investors are [ __ ] to it and
people are signing up a late into the
evening talking and generating their
ideas as you might hope there's some
concern that with all these English
language people are showing up in Turkey
and Hungary everywhere else that we're
sort of trying to take the best of what
in the world has to offer for ourselves
and it it's sort of I've heard from
other people this or like an American
egoism
you know to count all these places you
just start up and say I like it what do
you what do you respond to those critics
I know it leaves us reeling sometimes
you know we don't we just want to
explore we want to live it well the
implication is that you're reading
somebody else out who is more
appropriate but who is it who is it
Peyton there's no money with the Germans
be preferable with the Japanese be
preferable I think that the Czechs
should see it as an extraordinary piece
of good fortune in terms of the hard
currency the
close in here no one will stay who
doesn't become partially check so it's
and if what people are simply resisting
is being cosmopolitan well then what
planet are they planning to move to
because you know in Kathmandu their
discos in Bali there's there's no
escaping modern high-tech culture and to
call it American when you go to Dresden
in East Germany the whole thing is being
played out with no Americans there it's
West German it's being resented by East
Germans so I think that you always have
a situation of those who are not moving
forward representing and blaming those
who are but if you get into cultural
stereotyping it's a kind of racism or
something I mean in other words we do
not represent IBM or General Motors we
don't even represent them when we're in
the some of the states so to talk about
the American invasion there's a
corporate invasion there's a youth
invasion and I think checks should feel
very differently about these things do
you think they're developing along their
own lines or do you see it as sort of a
period of stagnancy with this political
and economic uncertainty do you feel and
I think things that there's a lot of
thrashing around and that it will
continue until the country is actually
that this federal issue is settled I
think that a lot of people haven't
thought beyond the breakup of the
country and once that settled and it
appears to me that it's inevitable then
Bohemia will define itself and Western
Czechoslovakia will do
itself differently back to the Bohemian
is to when when would you like to see
the doors open when what is your
personal goal for this project well over
the summer I'd I would hope that
sometime in the fall the doors would
open here this fall and yeah and then it
would be up and running by the middle of
next year and all areas of concern and
you say you're looking at everything is
the biggest problem finding the actual
place that would accommodate the you
know have nice walls for gallery space
and these plays were cafe is that the
biggest problem and the biggest problem
is also raising money yeah honey we're
in a funny situation now because we've
just had conferences with a number of
people who probably will give money but
they have to complete their European
vacation and I have to have many things
with them in California and it's a pain
in the neck to me because I would rather
stay here and hassle through getting a
space right now
but considering kind of energy it has I
don't think it has to be pushed see when
you say one last thing I notice the the
gallery let's kind of stuff with it just
before American artists or would it just
before any any capable ours who came in
that had something interesting no I
think I chef Cardoz
said I was it would be at the top of the
list the idea would be to show Czech
artists to get them in front of
galleries in the West and to bring
artists here to give them exposure in
the East so somewhat of a springboard
idea right it's - it's an educational
it's to educate people going both ways
what have you thought of the Czech art
you've seen so far it falls into two
categories technically competent but not
very interesting and world-class
experimental stuff that can stand on its
own that tends to be in the surreal or
Mannerist category what's what medium in
particular you say the the world-class
experimental stuff I mean is it pain
pain things do you think specifically
you mentioned that the the technical
skill is often very apparent that they
seem to be saying that the Czech artists
and not all of them because generally
that their big focus is trying to be
technical and trying to be accepted do
you see that as something that we talk
about you're into education resituate
ear we try and sort of hammer away a
barrier of sorts as to how they think
and perceive well I think they've been
operating in a vacuum away from the
influence of anything else
and once this ends I imagined they will
enter the stream of world
orange
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay perfect